non ça va aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on y
regarder on à la poste on n'est pas dans
un bureau de poste on est ici aviva
texte salon vives attaques 2022 vive
attaque revient et ça c'est chouette on
est à paris alors aujourd'hui on va
parler de quoi on parlait de la poste la
verrue salaires ya beaucoup
d'innovations du côté de la poste on va
venir par les véhicules de nome qui va
venir aider les facteurs ça c'est plutôt
chouette on va parler de livraison par
dronne on va parler d'exosquelette qui
l'avenir éviter la fatigue tout
simplement envie reparler de plein de
sujets super intéressant on le fait
aujourd'hui aviva tech 60 de la poste
vous est pris on y va au clap clap
[Musique]
la peau reste révolution également au
niveau de la mobilité alors vous
connaissez toutes les problématiques de
mobilité les villes qui se révolutionne
des villes qui change qui évolue c'est
compliqué pour circuler alors déjà la
poste ils font un truc c'est que le
terreau nitti j'enlève mes maîtres de
l'électrique ça c'est déjà bien ça
avance ils mettent des vélos 15 euros
vous pourrez en faire un peu plus assez
de vachement bien notamment pour les
postillons va plus loin au niveau du
véhicule autonome ça c'est carretta
alors carretta ça va commencer à
circuler à montpellier le 4 juillet 2022
on va voir un véhicule from eric
l'autonome en france qui va rouler c'est
signé la poste alors qu'est ce qu'il
vient faire car état et bien il vient
pas remplacer un postier c'est pas le
but c'est pas l'idée il vient l'aider il
vient d'assister lorsque votre post est
bien avancé notamment sur la livraison
colis lui qu'est ce qu'il va faire et
bien l'avoir tard il est passé là il est
passé là à t il falloir que j'ai dû
emmener quelques colis en plus car états
arrivent tout seul il fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin il arrive et paf
votre post il n'y a plus qu'à récupérer
des colis donc ça c'est cool comment ça
se passe on a une petite carte regardez
ça se passe juste ici pas de postiers il
vient il pose ça ça va venir sourire et
il peut venir récupérer ces différents
coliques à pouvoir livrer et si la
febiac collecte par exemple chez un
particulier ou dans une entreprise peut
prendre ces colis les reposer il passe
donc ça c'est extrêmement pratique et
puis pour vous monsieur et madame tout
un chacun vous balader en ville voyez
quart et a fait un petit coucou vous
pouvez venir poster votre courrier en
gros c'est la poste qui vient vous avez
plus besoin de trouver la boîte vous
prenez hop vous glisser dedans et c'est
parti et de la même manière qu'en quarts
étant reviendra à la maison à parvenir à
l'ouvrir récupérer ça c'est vachement
bien donc on jouera comment est-ce que
la poste arrive à se révolutionner non
pas pour remplacer de l'homme par des
robots est tout simplement pour venir
réinventer la mobilité qui participent
complètement avec différents capteurs on
a des capteurs lidar en haut en bas au
regard des caméras caméra 2d caméra 3d
qui viennent maps et la route et vous
avez également des ultrasons un peu tous
les côtés pour réussir à voir ce qui se
passe parce que votre petite caméra est
sympa mais libéraux relevant qu'à
travers donc ça c'est vachement bien et
au delà de ça sont malins la poste ils
ont mis en place de nouveaux services
comme ici ce système qui est un capteur
du service en fait si on me l'a proposé
à différents partenaires du privé soir à
partenaires état pourquoi pas pour venir
l'état voir l'état des routes pour bien
voir pas mal de choses vous voyez on
voit également que le business model de
la poste se réinvente la mobilité change
et son acteur important premier véhicule
autonome qui à prendre la route en
france constitués entre un véhicule
catégorie 3 à 4 on avance on n'est pas
là pour remplacer l'humain mais c'est
cool et en plus il fait des petits clins
d'oeil canal
[Musique]
or on parle de véhicules autonomes on
parle d'aider les facteurs ça c'est bien
mais maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe
si vous habitez par exemple dans un
village de montagne qui est totalement
une geôle est si vous êtes sur une île
j'en sais rien une petite île où il n'y
a pas beaucoup de colis qui arrive eh
bien il ya une autre solution que
développe la fosse était extrêmement
intéressant sur laquelle ils bossent
déjà depuis 2016 c'est le drone la
livraison par drones alors je sais pas
dites le moi comment tu as mais pour moi
la livraison par ron c'est un truc un
petit peu de la science fiction les
drones volent attention ces fermes et
j'imagine n'est pas aujourd'hui que la
poste déjà voler des drones pour venir
faire la livraison eh bien oui c'est le
cas et ça c'est vachement bien alors
c'est un gros drone peut mettre des
charges jusqu'à 10 kg l'idc vous faites
10 kg net avec dix kilos de charge et
ils nous ont montré une démo c'est
extrêmement cool parce que vous prenez
un opérateur qui avec son camion qui se
tient dans la vallée le drone fort vous
avez un opérateur à distance qui lui va
vérifier que drone parrot bon endroit et
cet opérateur il regarde juste alors
c'est pas quelqu'un de la poste c'est un
prestataire le drones volent une vielle
argué le colis directement dans un
endroit dédié et là vous avez quelqu'un
soit un commerçant du bois soit
quelqu'un de la municipalité qui vient
qui récupère le colis et qui va livrer
sur les derniers kilomètres seront
classés vachement bien pourquoi il ya
tout simplement parce que c'est
compliqué de sa montée un camion dans la
montagne pendant je sais pas combien de
temps pour un ou deux canidés pour
autant ces personnes qui vivent dans ces
endroits là ils ont besoin d'avoir des
colis faut pas qu'ils soient isolés donc
la livraison de la solution par drones
c'est vachement intéressant ça résout
des problèmes aujourd'hui la poste avait
du mal à résoudre convoque ça commence à
arriver pour l'instant dans les zone un
peu isolée on le voit dans le var on le
voit également dans un village pas loin
de grenoble dans la montagne mais à
terme dans dix ans cela pourrait arriver
dans ville pour la livraison en ville
faire gagner du temps être un complément
livraison en plus des facteurs donc une
fois de plus est ce qu'on vous réussit à
vive attaque est génial c'est que la
poste et dans le futur vécu autonome
livré aux paroles et c'est le début
d'une histoire
[Musique]
entre innovation signée la poste et un
exosquelette alors rider c'est pas de
faire peur on n'est pas robocop l'idée
ici c'est de venir aider les personnes
qui vont soulever des charges un peu
loin de là j'ai quoi j'ai vingt kilos
alors sera pas me faire pousser les bras
c'est pas le but mais par contre ça va
venir éviter de me flinguer les
lombaires jumeaux de l'histoire je
prends la caisse et hop et lui casse qui
fait med a levé directement alors là on
m'a mis à 70% de lever mais si vous
voyez ça me jette la première fois en
fait quand je suis comme ça arriver tout
seul je peux m'amuser je peux faire la
ola par exemple c'est pratique mais
sinon lorsque je reprends d'une caisse
comme ça c'est extrêmement simple
prendra caisse et là ça vient ça m'a
élevé donc le truc est assez marrant et
on voit comment est ce qu'on arrive au
travers d'une innovation qui est
vachement intelligente à venir apporter
du bénéfice aux personnes qui viennent
travailler à la poste alors ça servira
pas forcément le client final alors ce
que vous avez mis à recevoir des colis
n'est pas content pour tous ceux qui
bossent d'arrière préparé qui ont des
charges non croyez moi c'est extrêmement
important à leon serait une et aux
lapins dernière phrase est prêt
voilà façon elle est pas mal
[Musique]
puisqu'on parle d'un exosquelette y en a
un autre qui exposait ses habits
bataille sur le stand de la poste qui
voyez vous avez un fauteuil roulant
alors je vous explique un peu l'histoire
en fait ça permet à quelqu'un qui est
paraplégique de pouvoir se lever et de
marcher alors pour autant il n'y a pas
de magie aujourd'hui c'est pas quelque
chose qui est disponible dans le
commerce mais c'est vraiment le début
l'histoire c'est dorine bourneton qui
est effectivement une femme qui est
acquis et paraplégique qui en plus
championne de voltige qui pour l'instant
travaille dessus avec des équipes de
chercheurs et médecins et peut se lever
et peut marcher alors c'est balbutiant
ses débuts l'histoire attention on n'est
pas vraiment quelque chose pour le grand
public tout de suite mais on voit que ça
commence à se faire et je trouve cette
rue qui est vraiment vraiment génial
pour pouvoir apporter de la mobilité à
des personnes qui n'en n'ont pas
nécessairement qui sont toutes en
difficulté pour ça c'est un exosquelette
qu'on voit ici on a vu différents usages
de l'exosquelette exosquelette va vous
aider pour venir porter des charges
lourdes ça c'est vachement cool est là
pour de la santé donc voilà c'est juste
le temps vous connaissez la poste les
colis ça vous le savez également de
saric s'appelle place des services à la
poste où tu es vachement intéressant
c'est un système de consigne par exemple
vous commandez un colis qui va être
posée là vous venait le chercher quand
vous vous est alors ça vous génère un
petit merkel notamment celui là regarder
jouer franc-jeu lien ici je scanne
montcuq berthold je veux déposer un
colis je suis un utilisateur la taille
du collyre c'est un très gros colis et
de là je viens scanner le code-barres
babolat hommes ont quasi arrive je vais
déposer mon colis par exemple que j'ai
envoyée par vintage compagnie hop là je
prends jour je le dépose directement à
l'intérieur je referme donc la haute
volée différentes étapes qui s'affiche
terminé ça se ferme et mon colis par
directement ça me permet d'envoyer mes
colis quand je le souhaite de venir les
récupérer quand je le souhaite la nuit
le matin quand vous voulez c'est vous
qui voyez c'est votre problème chez
belgique mais c'est pratique et ça c'est
vachement intéressant pour ça fait
partie des services qui vont venir vous
aider pour solutionner votre vie
faciliter votre vie grâce à la pose pas
mal autre service qui est intéressant du
côté de la poste et la livraison de
colis dans un gros casier partagé alors
je vous explique l'histoire ça c'est
quasi double retrouver dans l'immeuble
de votre copropriété de votre maison
donc à plusieurs personnes le livre
arrive is khan il vient poser votre
colis et referme la porte vous vous
arrivez à vos smartphones et grâce à y
coller le champ bluetooth vous
déverrouillez vous ouvrez vous vous
dites quel est mon colis il ya votre nom
de ces pratiques non mais vous trouvez
votre colis et ce qui est plutôt malin
enfin c'est que vous avez une petite
balance en bas qui va connaître le poids
de votre colis qui va donc être sûrs
grâce au bluetooth que c'est bien déjà
vous qui a ouvert la porte ensuite que
vous preniez bien le colis qui vous
attribuez parce que on a le poids il
renseigné vous n'avez plus qu'à fermer
et le tour est joué donc le truc est
vachement mal hein parce que au lieu
d'avoir des grandes boîtes aux lettres
pour avoir des grands casiers ce qui
prend une place de dingue vous avez
juste cette grosse consignes en gros à
la nuance pas réellement une consigne
savait pas de grosse boîte pour les
colis et c'est vachement cool vous
partagez avec vos voisins chacun prend
le colis qui lui attribuer on le voit
par le poids c'est sécurisé et c'est
chouette pas mal vous en pensez-quoi
health innovation elle vous intéresse ça
peut solutionner vous le verriez chez
vous ou alors pas du tout marquez lui en
bas en commentaire aulas on a fait un
tour du stand de la poste avait vu
toutes les innovations il y en a de tous
les côtés du côté de la mobilité et du
goûter les exosquelettes c'est vachement
intéressant à 360° sais pas si vous
aurez appris des trucs qui vous avez
découvert un petit peu comment ça marche
et toutes ces nouveautés signées la
poste alors moi j'étais encore un petit
peu loin de savoir tout ça je suis très
heureux d'avoir fait cette vidéo pour
découvrir ses solutions solutions
livraison le drone vous saviez j'ai pas
partir en vélo j'ai pas droit mais avec
un petit coup de sonnette ont fait
plaisir on vivre avec ça c'est chouette
petit moi c'est un truc qui vous ont
intéressé qu est ce que vous avez retenu
de cette vidéo par quelques mois en bas
en commentaire et si vous avez un petit
conseil et donne à la poste une idée
alors ne vous plaignez pas pour vos
colis ça je veux pas entendre attend
sereinement vers des solutions qui vont
être dingue pour ça si vous avez des
petits conseils de mobilité pour de la
livraison prochain 10 km pour la poste
allez-y marque ailée juste en bas en
commentaire merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo à très bientôt pour le soin
de vous embrasse puma je pars pas en
vélo mais je klaxonne et ça c'est cool
allez à bientôt
[Musique]